Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
Merry Christmas, Ruffians!
It may be Christmas, but it's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not Fuwa Santa, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Moco Santa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for a very special episode.
That only happens once a year.
Once a year!
The Christmas episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Moco-chan, today we're putting the sea into... Christmas.
The Sea of Christmas into FUWAMOCO Morning!
I don't think we have anything to do with the Sea of Christmas.
I don't know.
Ruffians, do you understand?
It's Christmas, no more misunderstanding.
BAU BAU!
I hope for any Ruffians that are maybe early to see if Moco Santa brought them anything.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's a short format morning show held
Every Friday, Wednesday, Monday, and even Christmas too!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Is hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
Did Moco-san to visit you?
I'm just curious.
Moco-chan, maybe we got some photos.
Wow!
It does seem like we had another Pero Sighting.
Let's see what we have here!
De-den!
Yup, I think Moco-Santa visited this Ruffian last night.
Look at all those presents.
So beautifully and carefully wrapped up there, you know.
Waiting for you underneath the Christmas tree.
But, uh, the one in the center there... Kinda looks a bit familiar, huh?
Yeah, I recognize the silhouette.
This present likes to move around when you turn away.
Sometimes you can even hear a creepy laugh coming from it too.
Well that is, uh, lovely.
Yes.
I love it when my toys make sounds like that.
Creepy laugh.
Could it be like, you know, when you have like a stuffed animal and you give it a nice big hug, it makes a cute sound?
Is it like that?
I don't think it is.
Not this time.
We hope that Moco-Santa brought everything you asked for!
Maybe not this, but other things.
If not those, please know that Moco-Santa worked very hard.
And remember, that Moco-Santa also brought you that smile on your face too!
BAU BAU!
I want to see more Ruffians' photos, but... Well, we have important things to share, you know.
All this month!
I think you've had something to enjoy every single day after you wake up, huh?
Right!
Kind of like a Advent Calendar!
That's right!
The hololive English -Advent- Calendar!
But it kicked off right from the beginning of the month, and it's been filled with a number of silly goodies.
You mean Shira opened up every single one, right?
Well, you can check them out at holoen-advent.com!
There's a super cute webpage for it, so make sure you go and check it out!
I got it!
Moco-chan, what was our favorite video?
That's a hard one, but...
You know, we had a lot of fun!
But I feel like the first video was also very memorable for us.
Very silly!
I know that suits us.
We kind of became Christmas ornaments, right?
Every Advent Calendar will eventually reach the end, but there's been a little hiccup, and the grand finale will be reaching you a little later than expected.
But you know what?
That just means that you can look forward to it!
Look forward to it within this week.
Thank you for enjoying the Advent Calendar!
We're glad that hololive EN could bring a little cheer to every day of yours this December.
Yeah!
Wow, there's also been even more Christmas cheer going on within hololive English!
You know, our senpai, hololive English -Promise-, they just released a super cute Christmas song medley!
Animation too and you can find it over on the official YouTube channel.
It was so cute!
It starts with Jingle Bells and then it continues on from there.
I was really excited to watch it.
See our Senpais take on such great songs.
See which song they have to sing next!
Also, in case you missed it, we have some very cozy Christmas merch on pre-order right now.
So check it out!
Ruffians, do you know what I'm going to say?
Maybe they have an idea.
I really like the Festive Christmas mug and plate.
You know, the mug is very cute.
It makes you feel like maybe drinking a big cup of hot moco-kai out of it.
You know, yeah, that's the mug, huh?
Maybe it could be another mug for my collection too.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, we have a lot planned for the holidays for the end of the year here, but maybe, just maybe, are you still looking for a way, a fun way, to enjoy your Christmas today?
In case you aren't, earlier this month we released some very special Christmas voicebacks!
All of our ventures.
This time they're both in English and Japanese.
You can have a little listen to a sample beforehand too just to see what they're like.
FUWAMOCO, we had just a little bit of fun imagining what kind of Christmas we'd like to share with you.
We hope that maybe you'll decide to join us and have a listen to them.
That way we can bring a bit more Christmas to you.
Even more Christmas!
Are you ready for that, Ruffians?
One of you are Christmas Wastebag.
Don't have a Christmas Overload, okay?
I won't want that.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, you know, if you haven't noticed, it's Christmas.
It's Christmas Day today.
If you haven't noticed, I would ask you to check your eyes.
And well, you know,
We've been on our best behavior this year.
We have!
We've done very well.
What do you think, Ruffians?
We did a good job, right?
Right!
Right?
Check your eyes.
Hi!
It's Christmas.
We did an amazing job.
A great job!
I think we have it.
We made a bit of a mistake.
There's been a misunderstanding.
BAU BAU.
Abyss Understanding.
Ruffians, you know, during our special Christmas Among Us collab with hololive English, you know, something surprising happened!
Something even more surprising than FUWAMOCO becoming the impostor.
We were the imposter.
And unsurprisingly, everyone figured out that.
And they got rid of us pretty fast.
But you know, we whole grudges were the imposter.
We're not just gonna give up.
We're not gonna accept it.
Not acceptable.
So you know, when we were chatting as a ghost afterwards, we were telling everyone how we were innocent.
Innocent puppies.
Yeah.
And, and,
You know, Biboo, being Biboo, she saw through that.
And so, we said, forget it Biboo!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, forget it!
But, uh, among us didn't like that.
And censored me.
Maybe I was a bit too aggressive with it.
Well, you know, even at that moment, Moco-chan, I thought you crossed the line too, you know?
You don't need to take that toll on Biboo and Ame-senpai.
I really didn't realize that you're that kind of dog, Moco-chan.
I was just trying to be a good imposter.
That's what an imposter would say, huh?
I think you really shocked our senpai, too.
Even Ame-senpai thought that your aggression was directed towards her, too, so...
It was embarrassing.
I was embarrassed.
It was a big misunderstanding, huh?
Right!
I didn't mean to come off that way!
You get it, right, Ruffians?
You understand now?
Right?
Poor Biboo.
No, you mean poor Mococo!
It's Christmas, okay?
It's Christmas!
Hopefully, Moco-chan, that's our last big misunderstanding of 2023.
Yes!
It better be!
BAU BAU!
Last misunderstanding?
You're still a bit shocked?
I'm sorry.
I was pretty shocked too, but... It was among us.
It was a misunderstanding.
Ruffians!
It's Gabi-sumas.
It is.
So... You know... We kind of have...
A present for you!
Maybe you know that already.
Maybe.
But, you know, we wanted to add an extra present on your Christmas tree.
No, why is it just for you?
So, we prepared a new song of a cover.
A new song cover of a song that we really like.
A cover of...
It's a really famous winter song in Japan.
It's very emotional.
It has a really good meaning behind it.
So we wanted to sing it for you.
We think maybe with this, you'll be able to hear a bit of a different FUWAMOCO.
We want you to listen to it as soon as possible, okay?
So right after FUWAMOCO Morning today, we'll be going to the Premium!
All together!
We want to see your reaction, okay?
When you open up the present.
What we want to hear, what you think of it too.
You know, it's been a very busy time for FUWAMOCO, but we're really, really happy we could have this present ready for you.
Yeah!
Please just wait a little longer until opening, okay?
Only a couple more minutes, okay?
The premiere will be right after this, okay?
We'll go all together, okay?
So don't worry about missing it.
BAU BAU!
Well, speaking of presents...
The only present we prepared for today.
Actually, you know, rather than this one being a present from us, this is more of a present from Mama Puppy.
Mama Puppy, you know, she surprised us yesterday by popping by to drop off some special Christmas gear and food traditional to the Northwest Passage.
We thought that maybe...
We do our Twitterspace and put them up all together here!
So, at 9.10am PT or 2.10am JST, we're gonna be holding a Christmas Morning Twitterspace!
BAU BAU!
Sighted Ruffians!
Maybe we could open presents all together!
Oh, maybe we've already opened your presents.
That's okay.
You didn't need to wait for us.
I'm sort of curious what's going to be in the stockings.
We're looking forward to opening them up for you!
BAU BAU!
So many exciting things.
So many Christmas things.
It's Christmas!
Well, not only is it just Christmas today, it's also the start of the very last week of 2023.
So, you know, with even more passion than usual, that means we absolutely need to challenge ourselves to something new.
What is eggnog, Moco-chan?
I don't really know, but I think it's eggs and a nog and milk.
Is nog the milk?
I think I heard right.
Eggs plus Nogs.
Right.
Egg Nog.
Well, our history with Egg Nog isn't very long.
We tried some of our very little puppies.
Oh, he did it.
Yeah.
So we never had it again!
Never again.
But today we'll overcome those bad memories and challenge it again!
Okay, Ruffians?
You're gonna challenge it with us, right?
But, you know, interestingly enough, we actually have two different types of eggnog today.
Well, Mama Fuffy, you know, she probably heard that we're going to be challenging ourselves to some eggnog today, and she thought that she'd help out by importing some for us too.
That was really kind of her to hide!
Today we have a classic eggnog and a traditional eggnog.
What's the difference?
I don't know.
Maybe that will be...
Moco-chan.
Well, I don't think any farmers from Tochigi were involved in the process of making the eggnog.
So, uh, yeah.
I don't think so either.
But still, thank you.
Moco-chan, maybe let's say thank you to all the eggs, and the chickens, and the nogs, and the cows, and the farmers, and all those who worked hard for us today.
And Moco-chan!
Mama Puppy too.
And Mama Puppy.
And Papa puppy.
Moco-chan.
I don't know if I want to be a part of the corner like this.
Now that you're a part of the challenge corner, you don't want to participate?
Okay.
Moco-chan, you take- Why do I have to start?
We're both gonna start.
You take the classic.
I'll take the traditional.
At a glance, it's rather thick.
The colors are different too.
It's supposed to look nice, right?
It has a bit of a festive smell to it, but not in a good way.
I don't know, mine smells like fruit milk.
Fruit milk!
Yours is worse.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for telling me that mine is worse!
Yours is much, much, much, much more thin.
Yes, it smells like fruit milk.
What?
Nothing is wrong with my nose!
That's what it smells like!
Ruffians!
What is it?
There's little stuff floating in it.
Is it supposed to be like that?
It is.
It looks like tea grinds.
It does.
Just take a sip.
You say it like it's easy.
Okay, Moco-chan.
I don't know how I'm supposed to have this, but I feel like I want chopsticks.
That's not the way!
I have a straw and I don't want to use it.
Okay, Moco-chan.
Let's count down from ten together, okay?
Ten.
Nine.
Eight.
Seven.
Six.
Five.
Four.
Three.
It's scary.
You have the straw!
Moco-chan!
That's really sweet.
It tastes like fruit milk.
It took a while going up the straw.
Yeah.
It tastes like fruit milk.
That tastes like fruit milk.
I don't like it.
Is it different?
Is it that different?
It's really thick.
It's not good.
Okay, switch now.
They are very different from each other.
It tastes like fruit milk.
That was the other one.
Okay, are we gonna try one?
It tastes festive in a horrible way.
That's a traditional flavor.
I'm gonna try the classic which Moco-chan calls Fruit Milk.
Three... Wait, three?
Five... Four... Three... Two... One... Oh, this one's for babies.
What?!
It's Fruit Milk.
This one is not Fruit Milk.
That one's horrible.
How can they be the same thing and so different?
Classic and traditional.
What's the difference between classic and traditional?
The words!
Shouldn't classic also be traditional?
Traditional's horrible, Ruffians!
It's really, like, look at the resistance when you put the straw through it!
It just makes me feel upset.
I'm uncomfortable.
It's the same thing but different.
Why would you drink this?
Where are the eggs?
Why is it so thick?
Why does it taste like fruit?
It's wrong.
It's like, you know... Breakfast cereal!
The only other answer is... Together now.
We have to mix them.
Mix them together!
Yeah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna take out the straw.
You're gonna get everywhere.
I didn't spill but now the cup is very full.
Moco-chan, you- We didn't need this, why?
Moco-chan, you take one straw, and I'll take one straw, and we'll do the movie thing.
It's like that, the movie, the fancy drink, when you have the one fancy drink and then two straws, and you drink it across the table.
This is horrible!
Okay.
Five, four, three, two, one!
Why did you do that to me?
That is worse.
That is definitely worse.
It got worse.
Traditional and classic is not supposed to mix.
Worlds that aren't supposed to meet.
Ruffians... I like sweet things, but it's not sweet in the right way.
No, that's not something... No, not something to drink.
But if you like it, well then that's good because we have a lot for you to drink.
Please take the eggnog, okay?
Ruffians!
Not again, I feel like...
I feel like my head hurts.
We did our best today!
I don't know if this is something I want to continue.
We will leave this challenge in 2023.
Moco-chan, you know, let's try our best not to forget the feelings that we had here today doing this challenge.
And somehow, let's do our best to use those.
What feelings were those?
To push ourselves in 2024, too!
What feelings am I supposed to feel?
The taste in your mouth.
That.
No.
That's not gonna help you.
Nuh-uh.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look.
Do we have a Doggie of the Day today?
Doggie of the Day!
Doggie of the Christmas Day!
Today's Doggie of the Christmas Day is... De-den!
Senpai!
Simba!
You're so cute!
Look at you!
Simba's so happy!
It's Christmas!
Very peaceful Simba Christmas.
How does Simba bau bau?
Santa Claus is here!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Okay, when Santa Claus arrives for Simba, Simba goes like BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Oh, I like that.
Very exciting.
I think that's just how it is.
Yeah.
Well, you know, I can tell just from this scene of Pero, Simba loves Christmas.
Very much.
But no, not because Simba knows that Simba's gonna be showered with new toys and treats and some head pads too.
No.
It's not that.
It's because Simba knows that
We get to spend it together with you!
Yeah!
And you know sometimes there's also big fluffy white snow that gathers?
And that's fun too!
Pretty fun!
BAU BAU!
Cute!
And for our Walk of Christmas Day, do we have a nice festive walk?
We have De-den!
Those are some fluffy snowflakes.
Really fluffy snowflakes!
You know, it looks like you have a very, very, very white Christmas going on where you are, Hoi.
We're so happy!
I feel like I can almost hear your footsteps in the snow.
Crunch, crunch, crunch.
Well, we hope you're bundled up very, very tightly, very, very warmly for that nice walk.
You need to make sure you don't catch a cold, okay?
But, do try to catch maybe a snowflake on your tongue.
BAU BAU!
The question of Christmas Day, we have De-den!
Hello FUWAMOCO!
Been wondering since you played White Album, how many VMs did you both start but never finished?
The way you talked about this made it sound like the list was pretty long.
I don't know, you know, I think this is a very good question because the holiday season, I feel like it's actually a good time, a really good time to play visual novels.
But you know what?
Wait how long?
As we said and talked about before, we haven't finished!
As you know, Fuwawa got a bit discouraged because the RNG was pretty frustrating at times.
And you know, guard dog training, it gets in the way a bit, huh?
To be honest, you know, there are so many amazing visual novels out there that we wanted to play for many dog years.
And we've played bits here and there, but Guard Dog Training takes a lot of time.
So even when we start one game, we aren't really able to play it very often.
And then, you know, so a lot of times we just can't quite get to the ending of a room.
We can't quite complete it.
It's awful, right?
But our feelings towards them don't change at all.
It's just life that gets in the way.
And on the bright side, that just means there are a lot of amazing VMs we still have to enjoy.
Just like any games or books or hobbies or things.
But as for how long the list is...
We don't want that!
Yeah, so...
It's a long list.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the questions!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Your special Christmas submissions!
Remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make together.
It's been like that all the way this year.
And it's not going to change!
It's not going to change.
In 2024, it will be the same too.
So we're looking forward to many more FUWAMOCO Mornings with you.
As well as Doggie of the Day.
Walks, questions, everything.
Thank you for always being a part of FUWAMOCO Morning with us.
BAU BAU!
And make sure you use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Our next team we have coming up, we have De-den!
Yes, Ruffians!
You shared your most precious, your favorite Christmas memories with us, and now we're going to
Nice and cozy, all together.
And we're gonna enjoy them tonight.
Find a fireplace.
Yeah.
We can have a good couple.
Mococo and I have maybe some Christmas treats too, you know?
Let's have a very warm and nostalgic Christmas Day evening together, okay?
BAU BAU!
And if we take another peek at our schedule... Live Schedule 2023!
You have to use your eyes very well, okay?
You're gonna have to use the binoculars.
The futamagane.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's a crazy end of the year.
Please spend it with us.
You know, there's a lot going on so surely you can find something that you think stands out.
That you have to be there for.
Watch interesting stuff.
We don't know what the week is gonna have for us.
But all we can say
It's gonna be fun.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for this very special Christmas FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'd like to take this moment to wish you, dear Ruffians,
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Kuma Kuma!
BAU BAU!
Brian!
Eden!
BAU BAU!
Raridor!
Tremendous!
BAU BAU!
Zidane!
Copper Shelf!
BAU BAU!
Jelly Pot!
Tank Hopper!
BAU BAU!
Lucky!
Doggie!
BAU BAU!
Waltz!
Marble Panda!
BAU BAU!
Rice-sama!
Rikididoo!
BAU BAU!
Mushy Mush!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a Christmas day!
Howl of a Christmas!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Bye!